You know, my normal teaching style is going to the classroom and just fucking talk, but
you can't do that on Zoom.
So I've been writing lectures for both my undergrad and grad class and uploading them
to them.
So they like, here's the lecture and I'm just going to talk through it.
But I've been writing those lectures and the practice of writing lectures, especially
for undergrads, which I have, I don't think I've ever done that or maybe like 20 years
ago I did that.
But I mean, I haven't done that in forever.
And writing this stuff down, it's the same kind of operation.
It's like, okay, I've got to introduce these ideas that we're doing Marxist stuff this week.
And it's like, oh, economic determinism.
That's a phrase that you can't just say and think that undergrads have any idea what
you're talking about, vulgar Marxism.
You know, like, okay, let me explain this thing.
And one of the effects, I mean, it's good.
It's actually, I find it to be just entirely a helpful exercise to me of like, okay, I need
to articulate what I mean by this.
So it's definitely helpful for me.
But it also just, like, my lectures suddenly go from, you know, I had about what I thought
was a page of points to make for my undergrad class.
But my God, I got like six pages, right?
Like, this is two classes all of a sudden.
It's that slowing down of writing.
I mean, I think we talked about this in another episode, but writing lectures for my classes
has been incredibly helpful.
It's great.
You know, as long as it doesn't become dominated by the lecture, as long as I'm only giving,
you know, like 20 minutes of lecture for a 75-minute class.
You forget the extent to which, like, all your interlocutors, like for me, post-humanism,
you share all these presuppositions and terminology that you then have to unpack for somebody who's
not read those discourses.
So like, just the primary targets of post-humanism, you know, the subject-object dichotomy, all
those vulgar presuppositions of humanism, you have to explain those a little bit before
you get to the critique of those.
And then I'm critiquing that critique.
So it's like you have to...
That's right.
Yeah.
Well, and also, I also realize, I mean, it's, this is the rhetorical sensibility, of course,
but in my graduate class, I taught terministic screen, Burke's terministic screens a couple
of weeks ago, and I taught it with the kind of critique of an epistemological orientation,
like here's the problem with the notion of terministic screens and whatever, whatever.
And I was going through my undergrad class on sort of ideology stuff yesterday, and I
was like, oh, you know what, I'm going to add the terministic screens, but I'm not
going to teach the critique of it, right?
Like, in other words, what I'm going to teach them is just different.
than what I'm going to teach the graduate students.
I'm going to say, I'm just going to be like, hey, here's the epistemological orientation,
as opposed to here are the problems with an epistemological orientation, right?
Like, I'm just going to leave that out.
And I started realizing, like, well, that's rhetoric, right?
Like, it's, I am literally changing the content of the message because of the audience, because
frankly, undergrads don't need to know.
It's just not relevant for them at that point.
I can gesture to it and say, there are critiques of this, and if you're interested, follow up,
but none of them are going to.
Right.
So, I mean, at least for me, it's been really, like, I'm writing every day, like every day
now, and it's great.
I'm totally enjoying it, but I don't think it's feeding my, you know, the book writing.
I mean, it's not, I don't know that it's bleeding over at all, unless either that or my book's
going to become like a collection of grad level lectures.
Well, you know, this Heidegger stuff has been really helping, I wasn't expecting it necessarily
to really feed into a chapter that much, but the relationship between Heidegger's thinking
and Foucault's and Nietzsche's and all these categories that they all use, the overman,
the unthought, I mean, this is going to be a whole chapter now, and I'm already, like,
kind of halfway through it.
That's great.
And rereading, because I already have a lot of stuff about Foucault, but it was for that,
it was for that independent study with Byron.
So it was all, it was all affirmative readings, which is fine.
It's just now it's going to be reformulated through the kind of quasi-Hegelian lens, and
then the French reception of Hegel and Foucault's critique of Hegel.
So it's like just elaborating all of those, basically summaries of his books through that.
But it's been, this Heidegger, even the chapters that we read for today, like, I was like,
damn, I don't know, it was really late last night.
So maybe I was like in a feverish, like, wow, this stuff all make, this is going to go into
this.
I, I, but I was with you on this as well.
Like, you know how I've been like kind of whiny boy with Heidegger a lot and the sort
of nostalgic.
I was back on the, here's why Heidegger is so interesting.
And particularly in, for me, 9 and 10, especially like making the links, you know, connecting
that sort of spirit of revenge and the overcoming of the spirit of revenge is the being, the
it was, and the eternal return is the answer, right?
Like, is the, is the solution to that problem.
I was like, it's so, it's so neat, but not, I don't mean that oftentimes when I say neat,
I mean that in a negative way.
Like, it's too neat, but it's like, it's just the parts fit really well.
So you just, right.
Like you felt that sort of what, what, what I was perceived as kind of the slow slog through.
It's like, oh, I get why that slow slog through, like the, the things are starting to fit now
in ways and the, the motifs are starting to recur in ways that like, ah, I see how this
is constructed now.
Yeah.
I had the same reaction.
I mean, I started a, and about, you know, up until about halfway through it, I was like,
You know, I've been the sort of, you know, I'm trying to productively read Heidegger.
I wanted to try to, you know, turn him a little bit.
And I had such, I couldn't do that for the first half of eight.
I just like, oh God, this is, I don't even have a chance here.
And then suddenly toward the end or middle or end of eight, or maybe, um, where he's
just like blatantly poses the question.
Um, it's like, I thought this whole lecture series was about how we're supposed to be
thinking or like the question of What Is Called Thinking.
And we're talking about Nietzsche and, um, that would be an accurate observation, except,
you know, it's all wrong.
Yeah.
Uh, and, and then he's, you know, he gets into the difference between, you know, so yeah,
this is, it's actually the summary and transition, uh, of, of eight.
So, you know, I was just, um, like, I was just like this, the blink stuff, he's just really
forcing that and he's just running this whole like surface first depth model.
Uh, I didn't like that, but yeah, so the summary and transition section on page 85, we
ask what is called thinking?
And we talk about Nietzsche.
This observation is correct and yet an error because it blinds us to what is being said.
Hence, what is being talked about and what is being said are not identical.
We may have the correct idea of what is being talked about and yet may not have let ourselves
become involved in what is being said.
And it was at that moment that I started to be able to see how I, I just had to let go
of, of a lot of that, um, concern about questions of essence and authenticity and just sort of
like nostalgia and what just seemed like every once in a while, he just seemed to like snap
into an old man rant about, you know, why everything is terrible today and then just snap back into
metaphysics.
Um, and it just started to finally come together to see all of those as sort of in this coordination
of actually engaging, like performatively engaging this question of, of thinking.
And since then I've, I've really enjoyed this quite a bit more.
Yeah, I agree.
Uh, there, there are some moments in, I think, I guess this is nine for me that, and there's
sort of a side, it's like, it's kind of when he turns to the will that I started getting
sucked in.
I mean, oddly, cause I don't think of myself as a big, you know, Schopenhauer or, you
know, um, but, but in terms of like what the will wants and what the will is through
Schilling there and, um, but there are these little asides and this, there's a great moment
that I really wanted to point to on 95 when he talks about influence and that, that I really
liked of, um, he, he says he, he's, uh, talking about Nietzsche in terms of, um, the, the revulsion
towards the, it was right.
The, the, um, that the will experiences.
So we must think through the statement of Nietzsche with as much care as if we were dealing with
one of Aristotle and, and as concerns the definition of the essential nature of time, we are indeed
faced with the statement of Aristotle.
Of course, Nietzsche did not have Aristotle in mind when he wrote this, nor do we mean to
suggest that Nietzsche is beholden to Aristotle.
A thinker is not beholden to a thinker, rather when he's thinking, he holds onto what is to
be thought, to being, and only insofar as he holds onto being, can he be open to the influx
of the thoughts which thinkers before him have thought.
This is, and this is the passage that I really liked.
This is why it remains the exclusive privilege of the great thinkers to let themselves be
influenced.
The small thinkers, by contrast, merely suffer from constipated originality and hence close
themselves off against any influx coming from afar.
Right.
I thought that was just this wonderful passage because generally you would think of influence
as being the symptom of the derivative and secondary thinker.
It's like, no, no, no, it's hard, you know, it requires a certain disposition towards the
problematic of being to enable influence.
And it's not even influence in the sense of citation, right?
And it's not conscious in that regard.
But insofar as one is disposed towards these, what he would consider sort of fundamental or
essential questions, that's what creates the conditions for the possibility of influence.
And I was like, that's a really interesting, you know, reformulation of like most people,
I mean, in that phrase and the translation, who knows, but small thinkers suffer from constipated
originality.
Yeah.
It's a nice phrase.
I like that.
It is.
I loved all of 95.
In fact, this is probably the first time in my entire intellectual life that I have done
this.
I wrote LLL in the margins one, two, three, four different times on this page.
Like, yeah, I mean, at first and second, and even still into the third reading, I thought,
you know, like, all right, Heidegger, I got you.
Slow down, ruminate, be a cow.
And then, you know, I thought that the line was like, we should give this as much care,
Nietzsche's claim as much care as we would give to one of Aristotle.
It just feels like he just closed his eyes and, you know, plucked out some great thinker
out of the, and he's like, ah, it's Aristotle.
Well, it's also, because that's a, that's a sign of the context in which he's writing
to a little bit, because now I would put Nietzsche above Aristotle in terms of their, their thinking
in terms of like the canon of thinkers, like they're on the same plane, but for Heidegger
and probably for the philosophical tradition, Aristotle was the king.
Right.
And certainly, certainly in the fifties, I mean, this is, you know, in terms of the timing
of this, this is a kind of active attempt to rehabilitate or even just to habilitate
because there was no read to it, right?
Like to say, hey, Nietzsche is an important thinker, right?
In that historical moment coming out of World War II and the associations there, like, I
mean, I, I, I don't know, I don't know the context well enough, but it had to have been
like, he's putting Nietzsche on the scene.
Right.
In, in doing this.
And so to link him to Aristotle here, I think is, is a bigger deal than it sounds like for
us probably.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, not just on the scene, but on the scene of meta, I mean, the, the claim
that Nietzsche is doing metaphysics here is, is pretty, you know, radical.
And I know, like, I mean, I know Heidegger gets kind of flack for calling Nietzsche the
last metaphysician and, you know, thereby declaring himself the last metaphysician, like, but he's
still imbricated and blah, blah, blah, blah, to like, actually think about what we would
typical, like Nietzsche has often read as just sort of like a history of psychology kind
of person and to actually think about revenge as a metaphysical or like a metaphysical principle
or a metaphysical orientation.
Of the will.
Right.
Yeah.
Of the will.
Is, is, is pretty, yeah, radical for the time, for sure.
Right.
And I mean, he does, obviously he is scornful of certain brands of metaphysical thinking,
but you'd have to say he's not always that.
I mean, he, again, like you said, Nathaniel.
Oh, sure.
He allows his own thinking to be metaphysical at times.
Nietzsche, it's not necessarily a critique then, would you say?
Like to say that somebody is metaphysical or that metaphysics persists is not a critique
of the way thinking operates.
Now, a certain brand of that thinking that's purely representational or calculative or, you
know, business-like, I think he calls it, that's the bad guy.
But metaphysics itself does not seem to be an enemy here.
And I think he explicitly says that.
It's like the treasure of metaphysics is the unthought, right?
Like what is unthought within it?
That's right.
You know, so.
Right, its own ground.
I mean, in lecture 10, right, all metaphysics leaves something essential unthought, its own
ground and foundation.
And, you know, he's going to try to go after that.
So there's a way, I mean, I think you're certainly right.
There's a way in which there's a deep indebtedness to what he's calling metaphysics.
So it's like, I mean, I just always feel like Derrida is so much cleaner at these kinds
of distinctions.
You know, it's like, look, when you're talking about instrumental rationality, which would be
the term we would use for a lot of the things that Heidegger doesn't work, doesn't like here.
That's no more or less metaphysical than Heidegger's own undertaking.
So the problem there isn't metaphysics per se.
It's a particular style of reason that informs that metaphysics that he wants to problematize.
But yeah, I was just kind of bringing up the particular lineage of, and like Brody brings
this up, is the sort of move to declare someone else the last metaphysician in an effort to
declare oneself outside of metaphysics.
And the problem of like establishing the grounds from which one can declare an outside the
metaphysics is its own metaphysical movement, which ends up being like, I'm the, you know,
as soon as, so like, Brody says, ah, well, in Derrida noting that Heidegger noted that
Nietzsche was the last metaphysician.
Derrida is actually the last metaphysician, or thinks of himself as the last metaphysician,
and Brody tries to like get himself out of that.
Although I, I mean, that's to me what's different about Derrida is he's like, there's no outside.
Yeah, of course I am.
I mean, he's just, you can't be more explicit than that.
There's no outside to metaphysics.
There's no sentence that one can pronounce that is not fully enveloped in metaphysics.
Right.
So it's not, it's never, that, that, honestly, that passage, and I just quoted that from,
I think it's Structure, Sign, and Play, that passage is, was the origin for my thinking of
style, right?
Like it is the, so there are only different styles, styles of inhabiting those circles of
the circle of metaphysics and the critique of metaphysics, right?
Like he doesn't use the word style, but that's to me, like, that's what he's talking about is
all we're talking about is different ways of inhabiting the circle.
Yeah, I mean, I, one way of thinking of it is, you know, I think that often the impulse
to get out of metaphysics is a notion of metaphysics that simply pre-exists and that we're just
sort of informing ourselves of, and so to try to, which, you know, is, is, has problems.
I mean, there are problems of thinking about metaphysics in that, in that way.
And that language of Derrida seems to me to be saying, like, look, it's, it's not about
there being a metaphysics.
It's about there being a sort of a metaphysical dimension to, like, the, the, the performance
or the, yeah, the, the, it's only ever the doing of a metaphysics or a metaphysicking,
I don't know.
Right.
Well, in so far, in so far as metaphysics.
It's an action.
Yeah.
In so far as metaphysics now, especially as seen as a critique of thinking, I mean, you
could, you could argue that one of the symptoms of metaphysical thinking is the attempt to
get out of it.
So Heidegger's, Heidegger's occasional attempts to surpass metaphysics, which you, which you
can see, like, in the diagnosis of the metaphysics of presence in relation to the concept of
time, which he said, and you can see how that directly leads to Derrida.
Just in that diagnosis, there's the assumption that Heidegger is out of it or above it somehow,
even though he's not explicitly offering, here's what time really is.
Here's, here's how it's related to being.
Here's the better conception of time.
He doesn't explicitly say that, but just the diagnosis, you, you would kind of assume that
you are seeing metaphysics from above or from the, some other vantage point, you know.
You have to do a little bit of work on what, what diagnosis is and how diagnosis works,
like the symptomatology of Nietzsche, right?
Like you have to do that.
You're, you're quite right.
Because otherwise it would look like I am removed from this in order to see how it,
in order to show, show how it works.
Yeah.
But it's.
But that's where, that's where metaphysics is.
I mean, in many ways, as a term, it's kind of a bad target in that regard, right?
Like, because it does bring with it all of the sort of notions of being and presence, right?
As Heidegger points out, so that because it brings with it all those things, seeing it
as a target thinks of it as a thing.
Right.
You know, which is unsurprising that we, you know, so it's kind of like, not that another
word's going to buy you out of that necessarily.
It doesn't, but it seems as if, you know, I have to admit, like, I remember when I first
read Totality and Infinity, Levinas' Totality and Infinity, and it begins with the claim
of like, the only relevant philosophy is metaphysics, right?
It's, and this is written in what, like the 70s, I think, like, or maybe even 80s.
Like, this is not oblivious to the critique of metaphysics that's circulating at that time.
And it just totally threw me.
And it was just this really different way into relating to the, to the, to, to metaphysics
and saying, like, look, the only relevant questions are metaphysical.
The only relevant philosophical questions are metaphysical and that one is immersed in
metaphysics.
So it's, it's, for him, it wasn't, it so wasn't a question of getting out of it that he was just
like, let's learn how to really be metaphysical.
And I was like, well, that's an interesting tactic to take as opposed to trying to delimit
or reveal the grounds as Heidegger is doing.
Like, it's a different, different, a different strategy for how to engage the problematic,
the loose problematics, right?
I mean, if we were going to create a history of this, just like a sort of a general rough
history, and I'm curious to see what you think of this, you could say in some ways that
metaphysics, again, pre-Kant is an effort to understand the transcendent laws that govern
reality.
And post-Kant and Kant's immanent critique of the faculties, which are metaphysical operations,
then there's a notion of the noumena that, like, we recognize the sort of the performative,
productive work of the faculties and their metaphysical operations as somehow limiting our experience
of the world in some way.
And I wonder if it would be fair to say that part of the drive to get out of metaphysics
approach is in conjunction with a presumed real or noumenal that, you know, sort of like through
the existential movement can be, you know, it can't be understood because that would be
the importation of like a metaphysical groundwork, but it can be engaged in some way, shape, or
form.
And, you know, that would explain Hegel's take up of the exploration of self-consciousness
and its relationship.
Um, uh, and, and, and it's sort of like unfolding productive, uh, productive power, but it's that
like that desire to get out of metaphysics is in some ways a desire to get out of the,
you know, the, um, the bumper lanes of our thinking, right?
Yeah.
And the major contribution of Derrida is to say, like, don't one, don't pretend like those
bumper lanes are static in any kind of way because, you know, the very capacity to try to think
yourself beyond it, or, I mean, like there are an infinite array of ways of doing this kind
of labor that, you know, is not cordoned off from some outside world.
Right.
Yeah.
It's, it's, it's interesting as you describe that because the thing, as you were giving that
articulation, which I think is probably way more history, historically accurate than, than
mine.
Um, if I'm asked to define metaphysics, I mean, just sort of intuitively without thinking through
it, I totally am going to Heidegger, which is a determination of being his presence.
There it is.
Right.
Like that's it.
That's right.
Now the implications of that are, you know, so, so massive for all thinking, whatever.
Yeah.
But I, I realized as you were speaking, I'm like, oh my God, I'm totally indebted to Being
in time.
Yeah.
Um, and, and the sort of some, you know, he does a sort of summary, right.
Of being in time, right.
On, on page, you know, right.
101 to 104 or whatever, or whatever else.
Like, I mean, it really, it's just the summary of the argument of, or the argument of,
or the, you know, argument of, but, um, but I just realized like the extent to which when
I hear that word, that's what I think it means.
Right.
It just, it means that.
And, and it's like, that actually is Heidegger's contribution.
It's not just what metaphysics has always been thought of, which is what, I mean, it's one
of the reasons, cause I've always wondered why Derrida feels so indebted to Heidegger,
despite wanting to distance himself on the nostalgia and authenticity things.
And it's like, well, there, that's a perfectly good explanation.
Like he is the guy who gives us the rendering of being as presence as the problem or as the,
the issue or the sticking point or difficulty or challenge.
And I was like, wow, that's a, that's an enormous contribution, right?
Like Being and Time, right?
Like, yeah.
I mean, it's, it's in the title.
Yeah.
I do like tracing it back to Kant though, which you kind of alluded to Nathaniel.
I mean, and Zizek basically says this, like after Kant, the basic project of philosophy is
a critique or analysis of the limits of thinking rather than a project of like pursuing the capital
R real or being capital B being.
So it's like.
The noumen.
Right.
But like, I, I do feel like Heidegger can occasionally lapses into that basic pre-Kantian
project when he's after the authenticity thing.
Now the over, the way he complicates that in these last few lectures is sufficient enough
for me where I'm not like, gotcha, gotcha Heidegger.
But there are these moments where it's like, is the overman truly a, an authentic relation
that is totally qualitatively different than the way we relate to the world now?
And is that somehow pure being?
10 is the best one.
10 is, I mean, it is 10 is where he brings together, like, I mean, this is where the eternal
return.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's true.
The, the, the, the answer to the, uh, overcoming of the will's desire for revenge against the
it was, which, you know, again, is important.
It's like, look, the past, right?
Like, what do you do?
What do you do with the past?
The will insofar as the will desires eternity.
And the only answer for that given, given time, right?
Is, is, or the answer that Nietzsche proposes is the thought of the eternal return.
And that the, that's, that's why, and it, for me, it just clicked because, you know, having
read Zarathustra so many times and Nietzsche really just really says, this is the highest
thought.
It's the thought.
I mean, repeatedly, you know, this, this thought is the thought.
And it's like, ah, I totally get why he thinks this is, this is the solution to, is it like,
if you, if you think of the will willing, you know, not wanting to encounter a limit,
how can the will, will itself given time, right?
Given the passing of time is that I always sort of thought it is, well, one has to also
will the past as a becoming.
And that's hard to think.
It's easy to say, but it's, it's hard to think.
But I think that the, the notion of the eternal turn gives you that in, in his configuration,
this is not Deleuze, right?
Deleuze's eternal return as the eternal return of self-differentiation is different here.
This is the eternal return of the same.
And you see why the eternal return of the same is necessary in, in this thinking.
And in Nietzsche's thinking, I'm like, yeah, that makes, I like Deleuze's interpretation
and tend to sort of follow up, but I totally see why, uh, folks would want to hang on to
the eternal return as having to be the eternal return of the same, because that's the only
way that the will can, will backwards in a sense, like will backwards in time is through,
the thought of the eternal return, right?
The infant recurrence of sameness of the same moment.
Right.
Yeah.
I kind of like to, in, in nine, I'd kind of like to work through a little bit, uh, the
way he moves from, um, the, the discussion of revenge and its metaphysical qualities and
then its relationship to time for two reasons.
Like one, one, I'm just thinking about like engaging this conceptual material for our,
a listener and trying to like, just get stuff.
We don't have listeners.
That's not, we don't, we don't really have to take that into that much consideration.
Okay.
Well, but it'd be just good to get on the table, but there are two reasons that I really
want to do that.
Shout out to the listeners out there.
Who are these elusive listeners?
All, all, all 45 of them.
Um, uh, one, just to get a sense of the sort of like the, the, um, metaphysical machinations
on the board, but two, just to get a sense, uh, this will involve some reading, I think,
but just to get a feel for the, the pedagogy of the, of, of Heidegger's movement here, because
I think this is where I started to really, I started to see all of this stuff that in
the previous, you know, seven, um, uh, lectures, it just seemed like he had this, these sort
of like disparate sites.
He's like, Oh, I'm going to bounce over here and I'm going to bounce over here.
And I just couldn't really see the connections.
And, and, you know, the only thing I could get is like, yeah, there's a slowing down, slowing
down.
And then suddenly there's like a warp speed over to this place way over here.
And I have no idea how we got there and it started to just settle for me a little bit,
uh, in, in these passages.
Yeah.
I mean, the revenge, the, the revenge on it's starts on 92, um, and he's already introduced
the, I mean, this is after the notion of the will comes in.
Um, so the essential paragraph there, what's that?
Uh, first paragraph on 92, how then?
Yeah.
How does Nietzsche think the nature of revenge?
If he thinks it metaphysically, and there's a series of questions, but he says since long
ago, that which is present has been regarded as, as what is right.
The present moment, but what representational ideas can we form, uh, of what in a way is
no longer and yet still is the past.
What ideas can we form of that which was at this, it was idea and it's, uh, and it's willing
take offense faced with what was willing, no longer has anything to say faced with every,
it was willing, no longer has anything to propose this.
Yes, it was resist the willing of the will.
Right.
So, I mean, it's like, there's a way, a really great way in which, you know, how I always,
when I gloss the overman, I always say futurity and it's like, well, that's kind of the easy
answer.
Right.
Because of course, futurity is that which the will can will because it hasn't happened
yet.
The real challenge is to think of willing in relationship to the past because the past has
already happened.
And so how, you know, that's the sense in which will experiences itself as a limit, experience
its limit.
And, and that's the will.
I mean, and here, of course, by will, we don't mean a person's will.
Yeah.
Right.
We mean will in the sense of power in Foucault or desire in Deleuze.
But, but will experience is a limit.
It cannot affirm itself in an encounter with the past because the past is, has already occurred
and yet still exists as that which has already occurred.
So it's a, it's a limit point.
And that's what induces that sense of revenge.
I can't do anything about the past.
I can't will it in the way that I can will futurity.
So it's important.
Like, for instance, when I gloss the overman as futurity, it's important that I say, and
I mean, I did this in the book.
There's a gesture to this, but like future and, and also it's everything that I do in
terms of an engagement with history.
I try to do is that, you know, the history of philosophy in that case, but like futurity
has to be thought as not what comes tomorrow or what comes in a minute, but as a sort of
ethical opening to difference, regardless of its temporal location.
You know, so that you have to think, right.
Like, which is why futurity is a bad word.
Right.
In a sense, it's not a, it's not a very good word because it always indicate, it tends
to indicate the temporal what's coming next as opposed to like, in other words, just as
good of a word for as futurity would be history.
Right.
You know.
Now.
Well, so back up just a little bit to like, you know, how do we think?
So to say, to talk about revenge and its relationship, uh, uh, to the will or a will of revenge
and its relationship to the past, um, it's already sort of making the metaphysical move.
And I thought there was an important, because the, just the word metaphysics, you know, even
for me, like sometimes I'm just like, what the fuck do we mean by metaphysics?
If I had to explain that as a, yeah, super clarifying.
We got, I, it's a bumper sticker, metaphysics, colon, being his presence.
But, you know, I mean like the, the sort of smorgasbord that, that metaphysics tends
to take on everything from, yeah, being to time to predicates to, you know, like color
and sound and all of these sorts of things that metaphysics tends to take on freedom.
Um, I thought that, you know, the way that he's attaching metaphysics to representational
thinking is, is really important, uh, uh, the sort of like the metaphysics of representational
thinking or representational thinking as, as metaphysics.
Um, and I thought that passage, uh, on 92, um, right before what you read is helpful in understanding
that, you know, which says, how then does Nietzsche think the nature of revenge if he thinks of
it metaphysically?
We may explain the question with this other question.
What is the nature of revenge if it's pursuit determines all ideas?
And it's that determination of ideas that like, look, there, especially representational for
him, for Heidegger, it seems like ideas are representational concepts, right?
The production of representational concepts that now make the world around us manageable.
And he's saying, look, a certain will of revenge determines the way in which we develop ideas
and concepts about the world that makes it manageable.
Just slowly, like, you know, that's a, you know, there's, there's your, uh, uh, um, definition
of metaphysics, metaphysics, colon, the slowing down, the techniques of slowing down the world
in ways that they get manageable for human beings, right?
Right.
Conceptually through, through a conceptual apparatus, the way being his presence and the way you
May, and the way, the way you manage that is by taking revenge on difference, right?
I mean, is that, you are vengeful against the complexity of temporality and difference because
it disenables the pursuit of identity.
Identity is supposed to be a given, right?
Right.
Like I would just complicate that you are vengeful.
It's like, you know, I, just to add on, like what you are, in other words, it's not that
I have a feeling of revenge.
It's what the I is, is this spirit of revenge, uh, that you are a symptom of a, of a will that
is vengeful and it's expression of revenge is representation.
Right.
Yeah.
That's, that's what it does is it's making, makes it manageable for an organism.
But just, I mean, cause this, it seems to be a given here, but meditating on that as
a basic to, to the, the idea that ideas come from either a libidinal or a desire or a spirit
of revenge is such a, must've been such a strange concept, especially this time.
But even for today, nobody would say that ideas come from a spirit of revenge, that the way
that we think inherently is vengeful against reality or difference or relations.
Except Nietzsche.
Right.
Yeah.
Except Nietzsche.
I mean, there was a reason why he thought of himself as a posthumous thinker.
I mean, like, and, but when you get to the quote, it's like, you know, sometimes as we
saw with the etymological things, Heidegger's version of reading quotes is kind of like, he
might be taking a lot off a lot of license, but you get to the quote from Zarathustra, this
alone is revenge itself.
The will's revulsion against time and the it was like, okay, well, this alone, this is
it.
This is what revenge is, is the will's revulsion against time and it was, I mean, it's really
super straightforward there.
And again, this is what's interesting.
I have read that passage a hundred times and, and I got a sort of sense of it, but like it,
at least for me in reading through these lectures, I was like, oh my gosh, I get this now of why
representational for Heidegger, why representational thinking is a symptom of this underlying, like
all thinking, all ideas are a symptom of this spirit of revenge, which is why Nietzsche will
call the eternal return, the highest thought, because it, it seems to offer a way out or something
other than mere vengeance as a basis for thinking.
Yeah.
Right.
I was going to say, this makes me think of one of our episodes on Hegel, when we were imagining,
you know, like we sort of reverse that general, um, uh, relationship between like, there is
the human and then the human is endowed with the capacity to think.
And we, we thought and said, well, no, there is this sort of activity of thinking that, you
know, these critters that we call now call human got infected with and sort of, you know,
got infected with a certain mode of being that shaped its evolutionary pathways that, you know,
that, that the human becomes that the metaphysic physicking, you know, and, and then to, this
Seems to be an addition to that, to say that by the way, thinking, or at least this sort of
like meta, this version of, of thinking or this, this metaphysical thinking is essentially
a revenge against the becoming of life.
Right.
That's right.
This is where, I mean, that's a profound, I mean, even for me right now, and I hate to
say this cause we're just like on a, but like, even as, as I sort of think that I'm like,
that's a fucking profound, intense thought.
Oh yeah.
Right.
I feel like we need a moment of silence just to let this out.
I mean, it is, it's a good thought.
It's a good one.
It's a good point.
It's good.
He makes a good point.
I like it.
I really like that.
But here's where, since you brought up Hegel, I'm going to use my, you know, consistent.
I gave him a window.
Yeah, you gave me the window.
I know, man.
I was like, oh shit.
It'll just be brief, hopefully.
But this is where I think, especially the French reception of Hegel, which is mostly critical,
gets it wrong, for lack of a better term, because the spirit of revenge is usually attributed
to, like, Hegel embodies that unconsciously without critiquing it.
But to me, this whole, the dynamic of resentment, of revenge, that's the understanding, which
is like one of the first stages of consciousness.
Now, again, Hegel's not going to say that we surpass that.
It's the clumsy one.
Right.
It's the necessary but clumsy one.
It's the pre-reflexive, you know, consciousness, before self-consciousness, before reason, before
absolute spirit.
So the notion that Hegel just simply celebrates the spirit of revenge or the understanding,
I think, is a little bit mistaken, because you have the rest of the Phenomenology, you
know, after that.
Except for the engine is always going to remain that engine, right?
It's even as the phenomenology transforms the engine.
But look, it's there.
I mean, if we read on in that chunk of, I mean, this supports your point.
Yeah.
Boo-boo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We get a little, we get a reference to Hegel here.
He says, so this is right after what we just read.
The it was, the it was becomes a stumbling block for building, for willing.
It is the block which the will can no longer budge.
Then the it was becomes the sorrow and despair of all willing, which, being what it is, always
wills forward and is always foiled by the bygones that lie fixed firmly in the past.
Thus, the it was is revolting and contrary to the will.
This is why revulsion against the it was arises in the will itself when it is faced with
this contrary it was.
And then this is the part that's just like straight Hegel.
But by way of this revulsion, the contrary takes root within willing itself.
Willing endures the contrary within itself as a heavy burden.
It suffers from it.
That is, the will suffers from itself.
Willing appears to itself as the suffering from the it was, as the suffering from the bygone,
the past.
Right?
Like, I mean, that's straight Hegel, right?
The sort of interiorization, the production and interiorization of a contrary or of a form
of negation, you know, that is, in this case, generative, right?
Like, and going to produce a transformation of some kind in how the will operates.
So it's like, there's, at least to me, I don't know how to read it.
It's like a generative of a, of a ideational material, of a substance.
Yeah.
Right?
The preservation and transformation.
But I do think, you're right though, that the engine is, it's slightly different.
Like, the, the, the bridge to the overman, that to me seems qualitatively different than the
Aufhebung, at least the way that it's described here, because the Aufhebung is a transformation
where you have to pass through.
You don't totally transform resentment or negation in order to get to absolute spirit.
You transform it and sort of shift your perspective on it, but that dynamic is preserved.
The overman would seem to be a total transmutation where you're no longer within, you, you are
delivered from revenge.
It's not human.
Right.
I mean, it's not, it's really, I mean, that's where the overcoming of the human is, you know,
a substantial undertaking, right?
Right.
Well, it's, it's way, it's way bigger.
The transformation of the Aufhebung, it changes that ideational material.
It changes the, the, the, you know, the identity or the consciousness, but through the mechanism
of revenge.
And so, like, it's still animated by the same spirit, even if the thing animated by it has
been transformed.
Right.
Whereas the thinking of the overman is the, the, the, the, the deliverance from revenge
itself, which would have to be like a kind of liberation from the need, uh, to hypostasize.
Yeah.
From now.
Which is definitely beyond human, because I can't even fucking imagine what that could be.
Can't think it.
Right.
I can't think it.
Yeah.
I mean, it's difficult to think.
I like, cause again, like for Hegel, you have to pass through revenge in order to kind
of reflect on it or gain a different disposition towards it where, but whereas for Nietzsche,
that passing through, like it's almost like sort of just a de facto, like temporally.
Yes.
We have to pass through last man.
But at that moment, when you go past, then you're not even related to the last man anymore.
Like, whereas for Hegel, there's always that constitutive relation.
And that, and that's, I mean, I think, Boo Boo, you're like at the sort of crux of something
that's really, really important.
And I certainly haven't thought through it.
Like, I don't know, like Deleuze offers a diagram for the, the becoming active or becoming
reactive of active force at that moment, but it is exactly that.
How do you get from the last man to the overman?
Like, what is the dynamic there?
And is it, and certainly it's readable as a sublation, like, and people have historically
read it that way.
But I think that you're right.
There's, there's something else that he's pushing towards there in the thinking, but,
but I don't even know how to begin thinking of what it is.
Not that one can't, it's just that I don't know how to do it.
But I think it's, I think you're, to me, that's a fucking great moment that you're
It's different, it's different structurally from a sublation.
It has to be, like, even just the effort against Hegel, like, this is not negation.
Like, right, it points towards that, that it wants to be something else.
Now, whether that's attainable is a question, I guess.
Maybe that's not even important, though, for Nietzsche.
But I think that's great.
Like, look, I mean, to me, that's something that you could not have said or thought a year
ago.
Like, you know, in terms of that sort of, that moment as being, like, something that
is really fundamentally distinguishing, like, something that you would just call, it's not
Hegelian, but not because it's non-Hegelian.
I'm trying to think through that juncture just a touch, because, you know, one thing that,
one similarity between this passage to the Superman and the Alpha Bon having in common is a sort
of re-demarcation of all prior iterations, right?
Is that, you know, in the move from the Sophists to the, or the Pre-Socratics to the Sophists
to Plato, you know, it's, in each one of those movements, in each one of those Alpha Bons,
it's not like the past iterations get eradicated.
They get re-made in a relationship, right?
So there's a re-iteration of the thing.
The Alphabon, right, the Alphabon is not, I mean, right, the sublation maintains the
difference and overcomes it.
Like, you have to hang on to the first part, too.
Right.
It's very easy to think of it as simply the, well, that's what synthesis, right?
That's why synthesis is a bad understanding, because it's not simply, that would be an
obliteration of past distinctions.
That's right.
But the, but there seems to be something similar, but I agree, hold on to it.
There's also a difference here, too.
But there's a similarity with the sort of affirmative orientation to change as well that, you know,
in the passage from man to the Superman, the very notion of man would also have to be remade,
right?
As the expression, I mean, like, if you're going to think about the, one way I would think
about the movement of the man to the Superman is the expression of the difference that is
man necessarily leads beyond itself.
It can't but lead beyond itself.
And that expression of difference that is man would simultaneously, you know, not just be
a bridge to the something else, but also remake from whence it came as well.
And so there is also that sort of reconfiguration of what came before.
But I think there is a different, I mean, the engine that is driving both of those changes
makes the way in which the past has been re-articulated different, right?
That one, you know, the dialectical engine is predicated on marking those distinctions and
using the Marx distinctions as the movement forward, whereas the affirmation of differences
is, in some ways, it's a conjunctive logic where, you know, the conjunction of differences
express a new sum, a new sum.
This is where I've always thought of, to the extent that I'm able to even think it, so this
is super provisional, you know, like you can mark provisionality, right?
But I've always thought of that transition as a kind of, we talked about it like a leap
in place Heidegger uses earlier, but that's how I've always thought of it, is that shift
is one from revenge and representation being reconfigured, that the will that informs that,
it's not like you stop thinking or you stop having ideas, it's that what engineers the will
is no longer revenge because the shift to the affirmative disposition is a, it doesn't change
the content of anything at all.
It just changes how everything works and it's no longer informed through that revenge.
It is now, so now one begins to see representation as a symptom of life affirmation, right?
Like, so all of those things that we take as the sort of, that Heidegger takes certainly
as the problem or whatever, become no longer the problem, but the expression of affirmation.
Okay, so then let me, okay, so then let me, you've got me thinking now.
Shit, I didn't mean to do that.
I know, I'm sorry, yeah.
I mean, it's in the title of our fucking podcast, so, you know.
Yikes, thank you.
It only took me 24 episodes.
But, okay, maybe not the engineering of representation so much as the spirit that animates it.
That's right, right.
Right, so that, so driven by or animated by a spirit of revenge, representation seeks to
take the becoming of life and fix it and hold it and make it manageable.
That's right, yeah.
And dominate it, right?
Yeah, like turning it into the standing reserve, whatever, whatever.
That's right.
Yeah, again, as, like, out of a hatred toward life and, you know, the terror that it wreaks
upon, you know, the human animal.
Right.
But the passage through representation there to something more affirmative could look like
a spirit of joy in the representation.
That what happens when joy animates representation itself and says, now this representation isn't
trying to get out of reality.
It's not trying to stop or fix a terror.
It is now just a different modality of becoming, right?
That's right.
Or to use your language, it is a style of becoming that does not work against becoming, does not
hate becoming.
It's just like, ah, I've got my own jam.
I've got my own, this is my own funk.
To me now, this sounds so close to spirit in its culmination, absolute spirit for Hegel.
Absolute spirit, pure negation.
That it's difficult for me to negotiate.
Because I do think there still is at least a slight difference between the overman or the
affirmation of becoming and Hegel's absolute spirit.
But it's hard for me to, because they're so, it's just this very tenuous difference.
Yeah, it is.
I totally agree.
To try to give a kind of summary, a brief summary of absolute spirit.
So the understanding.
That's the negation of negation.
Right, right.
So the understanding as a pre-reflexive, pre-absolute spirit version of consciousness, it does not
acknowledge its ontological status.
So it does not want to be an appropriation machine, even though it is, right?
So it wants stable reality, when in reality for absolute spirit, the understanding is forcing
those realities through representations, etc.
So absolute spirit is just a shift in perspective, and it's to say that all life is appropriation.
And it's an affirmation of those series of appropriative gestures.
To me, the shift to the overman seems at least, I don't know if it's just an affirmation of
our appropriative mechanism.
It seems to be either one step back or forward, where it's a true affirmation of our differential
foundations, where you are basically letting yourself, you're giving yourself over to those
dissolutions of identity, even more explicitly than spirit does for Hegel.
But in other words, the greatness of allowing oneself to be influenced?
Right.
But I think that that would be, I mean, I think things do follow from the shift from the sort
of negative, vengeful disposition to what Nathaniel, I think rightly called the kind of joyful disposition.
And that's one of them, which is that at a certain level, it doesn't mean that you don't have ideas
about things.
It's just that you don't have the same relation to those ideas as being representational.
Right.
And one of the effects, one of the ways we can describe that is you just don't believe in
identities anymore.
Right.
And it's not that you don't use them, it's not that they're not, but that they don't
have the kind of weight or consequence.
You don't believe in the sanctity of identity.
Right.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I think the, in that sense—
Or you think of identities only as catalysts.
Yeah.
Right.
As relays for various kinds of things.
So it's like, okay, there's nothing, you know, I'm not trying to bust an identity because
it's just a fucking identity and we know what those actually are, which is not identities.
Right.
And that's where, so you see, I mean, that's interesting to me because it instantly bleeds into
Deleuze's version of the eternal return of the eternal return of difference.
Right.
That's the shift that occurs there is like, in order for the same to return, it has to
be different.
It has to, it can't simply be.
Right.
So it's a leap, like I would rephrase it as there's a leap in place that occurs such
that a dispositional shift occurs, but that dispositional shift is everything in a sense.
Right.
You know, it transformed.
Deleuze that we read in The Logic of Sense where the sort of like, it gave up the notion
of to die or like death and mortality for the, for dying and everything, you know, nothing's
changed and everything has changed.
That leap in place.
Right.
I mean, I don't know if he used the language of leap in place in that, in that series.
I can't remember.
Yeah.
But it's like a different spirit as animating.
Right.
But that's great.
Like, look, I mean, the other thing I would say that's probably more important than that
is I think the nexus that you're mixed up in, Boo Boo, is fucking awesome.
Like, it's such a cool, difficult thing.
Like, okay, I want to think the sort of, I don't, you wouldn't even simply call it the
difference or the relationship because those are two course of concepts.
But the relationship between absolute spirit and the overman there and like, how is the
negation of negation, how is affirmation not simply the negation of negation?
I mean, I think that's an absolutely fascinating juncture.
I mean, Nate, would you, I think you already did this, but it didn't click with me well
enough.
Can you try to walk me through the negation of negation?
Well, I mean, there's, there's a few different, I guess, versions of that.
Like, even within the understanding, there is a negation of negation, right?
So like, the, the, the first negation would be the appropriation of difference.
And then this might be kind of a vote or reduction of this, the process of the alphabet.
That's what I need right now.
Yeah, but that's, that's the early stuff.
I'm thinking the absolute spirit, which is the sort of pure, pure negation.
Right, right.
I mean.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to get at.
That absolute spirit must, must be, there must be another negation in there.
The negation of the negation of negation.
Right.
Because the, the understandings negation of negation is where you appropriate otherness
and then you, you negate that appropriation in the pursuit of identity.
So it's almost more of a forgetting of that problem.
That's where that second negation comes in.
For absolute spirit, it's, it's more of an affirmation, at least in the way that I read
it.
It's an affirmation of that process of appropriation.
Right.
So of course there's a transformation, but it's more of a dispositional shift than like
a qualitative, like, or like structural change.
I mean, if you think, if you, if you think of it.
So similarly, it's again, it's not like, ah, I'm, I'm after getting the appropriation right,
or I'm just interested in feeding the appropriation monster.
Right.
It's, it's, it's, it's an affirmation of our ontological status, which as Heidegger alludes
to here, but he's a little bit dismissive.
It's torn consciousness, which I love.
I'm going to use that quote that I've never heard that from Hegel.
Consciousness does not want unity.
It wants to be torn.
In order for life to persist, you have to be torn open.
You have to be violently open to alterity.
Right.
And that's, this is, I mean, on that point, that's where I've always said Descartes is
a bad target, right?
Like Hegel is a much more interesting target.
Because the Cogito is some sort of cordoned off, you know, identity is like, that's not
a problem.
The ego doesn't want to be cordoned off.
It wants to be open to difference.
Right.
The Hegelian movement is how the ego works.
Yeah.
And then the whole, the, the, the vulgarization of Hegel in that sense, it, it, it
makes sense if you read selectively, I guess.
But the notion that Hegel is just after unity, a vulgar sense of unity to me is simply mistaken.
A static sense of unity.
Right, right.
It's all, it's all movement.
Yeah.
If you think of it structurally, Nathaniel, I mean, it's just, it's, you can even just
say it as a logic problem.
It's like, okay, negation is the engine for the elevation of consciousness, right?
Like, we see how, how that operates through master, slave, et cetera, et cetera.
But at a certain point, negation has to become the object of a negation.
Right.
That, that, so, so that one has to then reflexively turn the engine itself on itself.
And, and what, what happens at that moment.
And so, for instance, in the Deleuze book, he says, like, Nietzschean affirmation is qualitatively
different from a negation of negation.
And he's referring it to that absolute spirit thinking.
It's like, it's something other than that.
Right.
I'm just trying to imagine what a negation of the negation could be because that, okay,
so if, okay, so if the engine of negation in terms of like the production of representational
ideas, right, let's just take that as an example to link it back to the Heidegger and say, all
right, the mechanism by which I'm able to do that is through an act of negation, which is
to say, all right, if I'm going to cordon this thing off, I need to demarcate its boundaries
by declaring what it's not, by differentiating it against something.
Okay.
So I get A, how that's a negation.
B, I get how that creates representational ideas.
And C, I get how that is a revenge against the becoming of life because if I can't do
that, fucking terrifying.
Right.
Okay.
So I get A, B, and C. I'm trying to imagine what that would look like when negation becomes
the object of its own negation.
Would that be a revenge or would that be an act of revenge against what is too much movement
in the movement of appropriation itself?
I think, I think the way, John, you described it kind of opened it up to me.
I mean, simply structurally, every act is a negation.
So even if that second negation opens up the possibility of reflexivity, so it seems like
an affirmation, structurally, it's still an appropriation of that initial movement, therefore
a negation.
So it doesn't have to be filled with the spirit of revenge qualitatively or emotively
or whatever, but it still is, structurally speaking for Hegel, a negation, right?
Okay.
So now consciousness and its engine of negation gets taken up as an object, which is itself
an act of negation, right?
Because you have to cordon off consciousness as a thing.
And we can call that a metaconsciousness.
So we can call that the elevation of one consciousness over to another, but what does that do?
It makes consciousness more manageable, right?
The terror of the constant becoming of consciousness is too much.
So the metaconsciousness presumably allows for a temporary, if insufficient, stabilizing
of consciousness so that it is more manageable and seems to be an act of revenge against its
instability.
Right.
Well, it's constant movement.
Yeah.
I mean, I think the emphasis for Hegel would be on that second negation, that the reason it's
not phrased as an affirmation of negation is because you're not purely, you don't purely
access that form of appropriation.
You are always in that mode of, in Hegel's words here, the unthought, where you are not
able to articulate your own mechanism.
So that is a constitutive mode for Hegel spirit.
So you can never purely affirm the movement of consciousness.
So even when you reflect that.
That revelation, so in that, in the negation of consciousness, there is a revelation that
one cannot ever get out of the negative movement and that there's always an unthought that one
can never reach because the effort to reach it is itself another negation, another appropriation.
Exactly.
Okay.
But that wouldn't speak to the spirit that animates it, but that would seem to get us
to a perpetual raising, right?
A perpetual...
But I think that's where the spirit that animates it is, I think, the thing that Deleuze sees
Nietzsche as offering that Hegel doesn't do.
Right.
Is that you have a shift away from the sort of elevation, elevation is not the exact word,
but the sort of progressive to like, that's where the leap in place, the qualitative shift
that Nietzsche is thinking of affirmation.
So in other words, the logic of the moves is the same.
It's the sense of a qualitative shift that redistributes what all of those moves had been
is the difference.
I mean, that's the way that I'm beginning to think about it.
But I, again, I really feel like I'm just, I honestly, like this conversation, I'm like,
holy shit, I'm going to be listening and thinking to this, this exchange that we're having in
indirect ways for like the next five years.
I feel like I've cracked open a nut and I'm just peering inside and just kind of pulling
apart of it.
Yeah, I agree.
I agree.
It's been really productive trying to write through this very problematic.
In the last few days, it's been like, there's just so much shit going on.
Yeah.
With all the think, every thinker is confronting this problem in some way.
Foucault, Derrida, Nietzsche, Deleuze, Heidegger here, Hegel, you know, and those slight differences
are, it's useful to try to delineate them, you know, because it's fucking impossible at
the same time to make a stark distinction between spirit and overman, etc.
But that seems to, I mean, to go back to what you were saying then, John, it seems like
that Hegel is giving the engine.
And the way that you've talked about this a lot is that, you know, Hegel often gets articulated
As the person who's like, hey, this is how things should work.
Or he seems to be saying like, this is, you know, because this is the way that it is, this
is, you know, this is good.
And your constant refrain has been, no, no, no, he's outlining just how fucking fascistic
and he's a case study or a warning of this.
The danger.
Yeah.
The danger of this total, like this, this form of totalization that cannot will its own totalization
because that would be its own destruction.
So it has to perpetually will itself toward a never-reachable totalization.
And that's scary as shit.
And it seems to be what Nietzsche is adding there is that you got the engine right, right?
But the question is, is what is the will or what is the spirit that is animating it?
Right.
It does one thing when the spirit of revenge animates it and the potentiality of a spirit
of joy animating the exact same engine would make a world of difference.
It would create a new form of life.
It would be, it would be a passage beyond the human.
Yeah.
I mean, the main, that's a great way of saying it.
The main difference is between the two thinkers, Nietzsche and Hegel, is that Nietzsche does
offer an alternative.
Now, that alternative is opaque and complex and difficult to tame because by its definition,
you can't tame it.
Hegel doesn't explicitly offer, right?
He stays within that engine of negation and refuses to even entertain the possibility of
a transmutation.
Whereas Nietzsche reaches, nobly, probably, you know, for something else, you know, that
would enable.
So this is also why, like, I'm getting a better sense of the difference between Hegel and Nietzsche's
orientation to history as well, because Hegel's orientation to history is firmly within the
realm of consciousness, right?
Yeah.
And Nietzsche seems to be much more broadly interested in a genealogy of wills.
Genealogy, not history.
Right.
Which, and I'm just thinking about, like, some of the stuff that he uses, you know, quote,
unquote, metaphorically in thinking about biological appropriations.
And, you know, like, he'll talk about, you know, this is the second essay in Genealogy of
Morals book, or section 12, I think, where he's talking about his version of interpretation
and sort of, like, interpretation of appropriation, right?
And he talks about this biologically.
It's like, hey, you know, we would think that, like, the utilitarian or utility-based
evolutionary thinkers think of, like, the eye as having adapted for the purpose of seeing.
And his claim is, no, like, the eye is, and I mean E-Y-E.
Yeah, right, right.
The eye is appropriated by the body and sort of, like, reanimated or given a spirit toward,
you know, like, toward a certain kind of seeing, right?
And that it's not like this thing, it's not like an organ is for something or an animal
gross clause for this purpose, it's like those clause are appropriated by a will to do something.
And then, as a secondary mechanism, a utility is sort of derived.
And so one way you could tell this genealogical history is that, like, consciousness is, you
know, like, the engine, the movement of negation that is consciousness and representational thinking
is an organ that isn't for anything.
It gets taken and animated or inhabited by a will.
That's not the only will that can take it up.
A.
And B, having it taken up by a will of revenge may very well do the necessary labor of preparing
it to be taken up by a spirit of joy or gayness, the gay science and shit.
Right, right.
Yeah.
No, that's good.
That's good, too.
Yeah.
I mean, this is not going to be a fully-fledged thought at all, but one of the, one of Foucault's
main critiques of Hegel, and he's not really named, but through Nietzsche, is their notion
of history, right?
And so Nietzsche's genealogy offers an explicit, stark, seemingly alternative to Hegel's traditional
history, where, you know, there's this real ego, especially to the notion that he is, he
himself is the culmination and the end of history.
But what I also see, like...
How cool, that's, there's a coolness to that.
There's, that's the kind of moment, it's like Nietzsche's "Why I Am So Wise," "Why I Write
Such Great Books."
I'm like, I mean, I just, I aspire to the audacity of a comment like that.
Like, "Ecce Homo," I'm going to write the story of my life.
Eke Homo.
Right, right.
Behold the man.
Yeah.
That's, yeah.
But I do think, though, I mean, part of that statement does contain something more Foucauldian.
I don't think Foucault explicitly treats that statement, but the notion of a progression of
history that culminates sort of linearly in Hegel as the progression of spirit and consciousness.
To say, though, that you're the end is to presume a rupture and a transformation as well,
which is what Foucault is after and what Nietzsche is also after.
There's little fragments and ruptures, and so, anyway, I mean, I don't need to defend
Hegel and his notion of history in this podcast, but there are ways you can reread the teleology
as fragmented and weird and strange and not simply this linear progression.
Linear, right.
Sure.
I mean, I don't doubt that, and, you know, and, I mean, in many ways, I think that a
point like that is exactly the availability of the past to its rearticulation, which is
to say that's the sort of, I mean, we didn't do 10 in terms of the eternal return, but it's
like, look, we're not done with Hegel, not because we've got to keep going back to him,
but because we don't know who it is.
Right.
And, hey, here's an opportunity to make one.
I mean, that's that sort of the joyful disposition to history.
Like, I find that that very move of, like, one can do this work, I totally agree with you,
right?
Like, one, I believe that one can do this work and one can make a different Hegel.
And such that the whole narrative that leads to that point would be totally changed.
Not just that point, but the whole narrative that leads, that gets you to have to make a
new Hegel would change.
So you can imagine in 200 years, it'd be like, oh, Hegel, the great thinker of affirmation
via the engine of negation.
Like, that's totally imaginable to me, but one has to buy a fundamental non-identity,
right?
And one has to buy the capacity of willing backwards in order to do that.
And that's the thing, because I find that most people do not buy that.
It's like, well, now Hegel is this, right?
Or Nietzsche is that.
It's not, you know, like, that there is this sense of, like, well...
Unless you're one of those revisionists.
Right, unless you're, yeah, exactly.
And those are inauthentic and they don't take it seriously.
So they become ways of deprecating the attempt to will backwards, right?
Right, right.
Yeah.
I mean, I think basically the reception, it's the way that we think about Hegel in rhetorical
theory or continental philosophy, the people that, you know, sort of associate themselves
with that kind of thinking.
It's just he was shit on by that whole tradition, at least the way that Butler summarizes it.
You know, Foucault, Derrida, mostly, except for Ingold, which is very strange and incomprehensible.
But most of Derrida's essays are pretty critical of Hegel and his notion of totality and unity.
Deleuze, obviously, is, I mean, he's the enemy, right?
That kind of thinking.
Well, there are a lot of historical reasons for that, right?
No, I know, yeah.
Like, pretty good historical reasons.
But let me also say, those historical reasons aren't all that different than Nietzsche's
historical reasons, right?
It's a different country, right?
But I mean, that's what I was going to say.
Like, I think the rejection of Hegel during that time period was probably necessary, or
at least there was such a desire for different modes of relating, say, like, right, because
of political or ethical conditions that taking him as the target was the noble thing to do,
right?
I mean, like, you are treating him seriously by battling against his thought.
So